frühstückszeit im schwedischen älmhult
wir sind bei familie vorbild grabe ist
die auswanderer familie aus deutschland
aus der korona quarantäne entlassen
worden nach einer woche endlich wieder
normalität mutter tanja vater tim und
die kinder jakob l und justus haben den
infekt gut überstanden nach schweden
sind die vogels vor eineinhalb jahren
gegangen der berufliche wechsel bei
ihrem internationalen arbeitgeber war
nicht schwer sie und viele andere neue
kolleginnen und kollegen war der arbeit
lockte aber vor allem auch die liberale
corona politik ich bin sehr froh ich bin
wirklich sehr froh dass wir die chance
hatten anderen weg auch zu erfahren wie
es hier für uns möglich war ich weiß
ganz genau dass mit der fähre jan
gekommen sind justus und ich sind
vorgefahren wir haben drei tage lang uns
unwohl gefühlt die maske wegzunehmen die
vogels fühlen sich trotz einer
derzeitigen zunahme der incidence auch
durch die infektion geschützt viele
schweden sind im kontakt mit dem virus
gekommen so hofft man auf erden
immunität vater team ist gepustet in
schweden ist das momentan an der
minderheit nur 35% mutter tanja ist vor
allem froh dass corona im schulalltag
kaum eine rolle spielt schuller war
eigentlich immer und auch sport
aktivitäten für die kinder weil einfach
dieses weil gesehen wird wie wichtig das
für die kinder auch ist gemeinsam zu
lernen gemeinsam sport zu treiben oder
einfach zusammen zu sein wir haben zwar
offiziell für abstand halten müssen
daran halten wird auch weitgehend aber
es ist halt nicht so mussten beide
tragen keine masken oder so
sie sind in einer welt gelandet die so
ganz anders ist als in deutschland
entspannter ruhiger
der natur
jetzt in der partie hier unterscheidet
ist das leben sehr und dem in
deutschland
es gibt kaum einschränkungen des
öffentlichen lebens keine masten pflicht
kein lockdown keine diskussion um
impfpflicht am anfang gab es pro eine
million einwohner deutlich mehr tote als
in deutschland doch in den vergangenen
monaten ist diese differenz stück für
stück immer weiter geschrumpft auch
wenn man mit kollegen gesprochen dieses
diese einsicht eine maske würde
vielleicht die falsche sicherheit geben
ja führt aber auch dazu wirklich dass
wir jetzt hier in der umgebung so dass
die leute wirklich abstand lassen die
vogels gehen co oder ganz schwäbisch mit
gelassenheit an hauptstadt stockholm
schwindet die bei manchen schweden schon
wegen maßnahmen die im vergleich milden
schein am vergangenen wochenende gehen
rund 9000 gegner des digitalen
impfnachweis es auf die straße der oder
ein test müssen seit kurzem bei
veranstaltungen im engeren mit mehr als
50 teilnehmern vorgezeigt werden manche
fürchten eine abkehr vom kurs der
freiwilligkeit mehr staatliche kontrolle
keine maske zu tragen das ist hier kein
widerstand auch polizei trieb
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nein zum impfpass jahr zu freiheits
skandieren sie eine der organisatorinnen
der demonstration ist die künstlerin
sandra wie green wir treffen sie in
ihrem zuhause bei stockholm sie und ihre
mitstreiter fürchten es solle mehr
kontrolle und zwang geben
ich denke in schweden gibt es eine menge
leute die beunruhigt sind das jetzt ein
weiterer schritt gemacht wird und wenn
wir jetzt nicht aufpassen ist es hier
vielleicht bald wie in anderen ländern
das ist ganz klar
er klappt
das beispiel österreich schreckt sie und
so wollen sie bei der wahl in schweden
im september versuchen eine eigene
partei in den reichstag zu bringen
es ist schwer zu verstehen was die
regierung gerade macht mit dem impfpass
das macht doch keinen sinn
wir sind doch gerade auf dem weg raus
aus der pandemie und jetzt machen sie
mehr druck als je zuvor die frage ist
doch warum
eigentlich ist stockholm in winterschlaf
und bemüht sich nach kräften fit zu
bleiben
von corona ist wenig zu spüren in der
wöchentlichen pressekonferenz der
gesundheitsbehörde eine analyse die
gegner des passes aufhorchen ließ
bei der instanz gibt es zwischen
geimpften und ungeimpften keinen
unterschied mehr die kurven decken sich
und das risiko sich mit kurven 19
anzustecken ist für geimpfte und
ungeimpfte etwa gleich groß
die impfung biete so vor allem schutz
gegen einen schweren verlauf infektionen
nehmen die schweden kauf ohne einen
nachweis ob impfung oder test kann man
so in clubs oder restaurants nur
überfüllt darf es nicht sein und es gibt
eine sperrstunde
sie schließen jetzt schon am 11 echt
langweilig immerhin ein bisschen party
geht das ist doch toll aber natürlich
verlieren die klubs dabei eine menge
geld man ist doch viel motivierter sich
impfen zu lassen wenn es nicht so viel
druck gibt wenn die bestimmungen offen
da sind wenn man selbst verantwortlich
ist statt dass man gezwungen wird und
man verhält sich vernünftiger hält
abstand wenn man selbst nachdenken muss
bei allen freiheiten den schweden auch
die fans hoffen auf die rückkehr zur
vollen normalität trotz aller gewöhnung
etwa das home office und man kann auch
vieker also kaffeepause zusammen machen
auch später aber es ist nicht das
gleiche ich habe es gemerkt ein paar
wochen wo wir jetzt wirklich mehr im
büro waren dass es dass ich das einfach
brauche ist vielleicht aber auch eine
persönliche sache ich mag das einfach
total gerne aber wir kommen ja wieder
dahin ich habe starke hoffnung in den
frühling
und auch die schwedischen behörden sind
optimistisch schon nächste woche könnte
der höhepunkt bei den neuinfektionen
überschritten sein